Interests and hobbies are very important
Equally as important as your partner in your relationship
having hobbies so you can come together
share your interest
or even share the same hobbies
it's great for any relationship
but what's most important in any relationship
is having the same taste
in interior design
probably the most important
because I don't know what I would do if my husband came to me and said oh
I really like neon colors in the house
or I like the 70s quirky retro aesthetic
because no..
I'm beige modern
Our relationship would not work if that was his style
don't get me wrong
we're not always gonna have the same taste
but interior design
it's very important
thankfully he likes the same color scheme I do
he likes clean
he likes the clean girl aesthetic
I think that's one of the most valuable things in a relationship